[Applause]
earlier this week it was announced that
in an upcoming dc comic the new superman
will come out as bisexual and people are
losing their [ __ ] we will explore this
now in a segment called [ __ ] please
[Music]
[ __ ] please y'all really upset that the
new superman will be bisexual he is a
fictional character he's not even the
original superman that's superman's son
why can't he be his authentic self are
you afraid him and lex luthor are gonna
trick you into a threesome you wish
look how handsome these men are you
could never now some people are saying
this is ruining my childhood [ __ ]
please
if a comic book character being bisexual
ruined your childhood your childhood was
trash to begin with
let it get ruined instead of being
fixated on superman's son maybe you
should focus on things that are
happening in the real world like school
shootings anti-massacres and
anti-vaxxers because they are literally
ruining childhoods also superman is an
alien from an alien planet humans are a
whole other species to him and you're
okay with his inter-species love affair
with lois lane but his son can't get his
groove on with a male reporter [ __ ]
please
lastly for those of you who are saying
there's a queer agenda or they're
shoving their lifestyle down our throats
i would like to say to you with all of
the power of my ancestors behind me
[ __ ] please
it is called representation so please go
outside and to the left with that
foolishness there is a child out there
who is scared and not feeling seen and
they don't see themselves represented on
tv and they can be made to feel like
they are lesser because of who they are
one day that child is gonna pick up a
comic book and see an iconic character
that's associated with strength honesty
and america and they're gonna see that
that person is just like them and that
it is okay for them to be who they are
and it will change their life that is
why it is so important that we have
queer comic book characters because the
only queer agenda is living an open and
happy life oh and saving the world from
upcoming meteors
this has been [ __ ] please texas
governor greg abbott on tuesday ordered
the state's child protective services to
investigate all trans children and to
prosecute their parents as child abusers
he also ordered the general public to
start reporting any transgender children
they see well you heard the man the law
says everyone in texas has to start
reporting trans kids to authorities so
it's only right that we give you some
tips on how to identify any trans
children that might be in your midst
tip number one the children so keep your
eyes peeled for anyone short vulnerable
and in no way a threat to you whatsoever
if you see someone that fits this
description there's a real possibility
that they are a trans child call the
cops
tip number two
they look and act like everyone else
so if you see a child acting totally
normal there's a chance they're trans
warning signs may include playing
hopscotch giving cooties shots and
having dimples
if you see a child doing any of these
things place a hysterical call to 9-1-1
tip number three
they are afraid trans people have a
nearly one in 10 chance of being
physically attacked in any given year
that's a real fear they carry with them
every day so if you see a trans kid make
things worse for them and call the fbi
tip number four they're experiencing
homelessness transgender and other lgbtq
identified youth make up 20 to 40
percent of the homeless kids in our
country so if you notice a young person
struggling to find housing do what jesus
would do
call a swat team tip number five
they're tired of your [ __ ]
trans kids are all different unique
perfect human beings but they all have
one thing in common they're tired of
hateful adults inserting themselves into
their business so if you see a child who
seems exhausted by your [ __ ] it is
possible that they are trans call your
congress person tell them to call the
president because that's a code red
hey
make sure to do it now before you
realize how utterly obsolete you are and
how the world has moved past its need
for you
or you could off a school district in
utah recently decided to suspend their
reading program after a third grade
teacher read her class a book about a
transgender child they suspended the
program rather than let their children
read a book about a transgender kid
i couldn't believe it now normally i
would spend five minutes on my show
railing about how the people who decided
to do that are complete garbage but i'm
having a nice week so i'm feeling
patient enough to try to talk to the
people who are scared to let their
children learn about transgender
equality i'm not sure how it'll go but
i'm going to try in a segment called
look at it this way
[Music]
hey hi there um i hear you don't want
your kids reading the story of a little
transgender child
okay well um that's really stupid
okay okay that didn't work but uh how
about this how about this
the world is changing and it's scary huh
okay yeah when people say things like
pronouns and gender binary it feels
scary doesn't it
okay that's better well if a pronoun can
scare you then maybe you should stay yo
dumbass at home
sorry sorry okay okay wait let me try
again uh look at it this way i know the
world is changing isn't it
yeah but that's no reason to deny your
children facts about the world the fact
is their world has transgender people in
it doesn't it yeah
look i know you may think that it'll
turn your child transgender but buddy if
they are they already are and as
powerful as this book is it can't make a
child something they're not
and when what's going to happen next
semester when you find out one of your
kids schoolmates is trans
hypothetically hypothetically
hypothetically what will you do then
right your kid will be all like
why did no one tell me this was a
possibility huh i mean hey your idiot
child thinks paw patrol is real but not
that transgender people exist i mean
what are you raising them to be
professionally dumb
oh sorry sorry i take it back i take it
back okay hey look at it like this
whether you know it or not transgender
people exist you're not helping your kid
by sending them out into the world
unprepared
it would be like you never told them
about birds they're gonna see one and be
like i wish someone had the balls to
teach me about birds because they're so
beautiful and they make my world a
better place but you won't and then we
have to deal with your dumb ass
offspring the transgender community
suffers workplace discrimination crap
healthcare violence at an alarming rate
and they gotta deal with yo dumbass kids
too sorry okay wait wait wait wait okay
um
look at it this way
the world can be a great place to live
if you're willing to fill it with love
and it is with love that i'd like to say
please
for the sake of humanity teach your
children that it's okay to be different
can you do that
great
idiot
earlier this month hundreds of high
school students across florida staged
walkouts to protest florida's so-called
don't say gay bill it was pretty
inspiring check it out hundreds of high
school students
are walking out in protest
if you're gay it's not hurting anyone to
be gay so the fact that they're passing
bills restricting these
rights in my opinion
but sadly despite huge opposition both
in florida and across the u.s that bill
recently became law it will prevent
teachers from talking about lgbtq people
and issues in their classrooms here to
comment is my head writer jenny hagel
hi everyone
i'm gay and i just want to say how
impressed i am with all the high school
students who came together in florida to
speak up against the don't say gay bill
at one school over 100 kids walked out
at my high school the only thing we
could get a hundred kids to agree on was
that the song hey jealousy was a banger
do you know how much teenagers love
bullying do you know how bad your bill
has to be for teenagers to say that's
too much bullying
that's like machine gun kelly telling
you that's too many tattoos
the point of florida's don't say gay law
is to prevent school teachers from
talking about lgbtq people in their
classrooms but it is so important for
queer kids to see reflections of
themselves in school
i went to elementary school in the 80s
do you know how many times we talked
about sally ride do you know how great
it would have been to hear just one time
that she was gay do you know how many
people my age watching this right now
just said sally ride was gay
i wish teachers had told me that
lorraine hansberry was queer that billy
holliday was queer that the guy who
invented computers was queer
also i wish somebody had told me i was
queer it would have saved me a lot of
time
it also would have explained this outfit
yeah
i look like paula poundstone's intern
[Applause]
look florida's new law is garbage kids
deserve to go to school and feel good
about themselves and they deserve to
learn about the world we actually live
in a world made up of all kinds of
people who are all equally valuable and
a world where hey jealousy is the number
one greatest bop of all time
everything you said was true except that
last part that's fair that's fair jenny
hegel everyone i have a responsibility
to say things that people need to know
that aren't being said it's a cool
opportunity that i don't take lightly
there are very big obvious truths that
no one wants to say on tv but i will
so
i can't believe i have to say this but
you matter even though florida passed
the don't say gay bill that prohibits
teachers from talking about gay people
in their classrooms you matter
children who are gay shouldn't sit in
school wondering if there are other
people like them they shouldn't be made
to feel like there is something wrong
with them and kids with two moms or two
dads shouldn't be made to feel like
there is something wrong with their
family there is nothing wrong with being
gay and cutting off an entire part of
our community will hurt us all in the
long run now they can stop us from
saying gay they can try to put all the
restrictions on you they want they can
try to get people to be scared of you or
grossed out by you and i'm sorry but it
doesn't change the fact that you matter
and another thing
i can't believe i have to say this but
stop selling luggage at the airport if
i'm at the airport i already have
luggage
you think i just showed up with some
loose t-shirts and a hundred dollars
you think i'm walking around with two
handfuls of socks like where can i put
these where can i put these
shut down that luggage store at the
airport and replace it with a store that
sells something useful like vodka
uh
and i can't believe i have to say this
but
it is wrong for there to be hundreds of
new anti-trans bills being introduced
across america this year it is not okay
to make trans children feel unsafe they
deserve our protection but it's a lot
easier to get people to vote republican
by making up problems like immigrants
are taking our jobs or black people are
going to come get you and i'm so sorry
that our trans community has become the
latest boogeyman you deserve better and
you matter
also i can't believe i have to say this
but
don't play music out loud on public
transportation
i get that you can't wait till you get
home to listen to thong song by cisco
i get it the most but that doesn't mean
we all want to be magically transported
to 1999 with you either buy headphones
or sit in silence and question your life
choices like a normal person
if you think it's fine to make us all
listen to your personal dj session
you're wrong we're wrong wrong wrong
i can't believe i have to say this but
think pieces about whether we should
teach school children about queer people
or gender identity are not okay
who you are should never be up for
debate the only thing those think pieces
make me think is that the person who
wrote them is a bigot
and finally i can't believe i have to
say this but
crocs are ugly
they look like colanders for your feet
they look like two little buckets that
lost a fight with a hole punch i cannot
believe someone tricked y'all into
wearing them
people are like nurses wear them because
they're comfortable well i think nurses
deserve better
i didn't bang on pots and pans every
night for nurses that have wet socks
that's not right
now i thought people were wearing them
because they cost a dollar but do you
know they cost more than a dollar
these cost 35
these cost 54.99
and these cost 625
dollars
man for 625
you can wear no shoes hop on my back and
i'll take you wherever you want to go
so
there you go the don't say gay bill is
trash luggage should not be sold at the
airport you deserve to feel safe get
headphones we can see through your
hateful articles cracks and most of all
and i can't stress this enough you
matter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you